allez on commence par le générique
aujourd'hui envergure épisode 24 on a
parlé des prospects internationaux de la
draft 2012
ce
alan est la pierre est là nico est là
comment allez vous messieurs sur le très
bon salut tout le monde
très bien très bien et vous ça va très
très bien aussi puisque nous sommes à j
- 9
avant cette draft nba 2021
elle ce qui veut dire au moment de
l'enregistrement
mardi 20 juillet que nous sommes au
lendemain de la date limite pour retirer
son nom pour les joueurs internationaux
retirer sa candidature
donc alors on l'aura pas ont pour nom
sera pas en mesure de vous donner tous
les candidats on en parlait justement
rente ai sera pas en mesure de vous
donner tous les candidats internationaux
mais on va vous parler de ceux qui sont
importants va dire ce qui pourrait être
drafté notamment au premier tour au
début de second il ya eu une énorme
vague pour commencer une énorme vague en
tout cas plus que ce qu'on attendait
d'un joueur qui ont retiré leur nom de
cette draft le la question d'abord ça va
être pour pour les français à alan pour
quelles raisons tu vois hugo besson a
retiré son nom alors mathieu les uns
c'est un peu plus longtemps
malcolm cazalon quelles raisons pourrait
imaginer pour qu'ils retirent leur
nombre draft bah c'est une question
toujours assez compliqué parce qu'il
faut se détacher de ce que nous on pense
du joueur
personnellement où on pouvait la voir
dans un classement dans un board avec
les retours qu'a reçu ce joueur des
franchises nba
il faut qu'on s'y emparer l'année
dernière tu reçois des pas des scores
mais peut-être des estimations ou du
délire au tu pourrais drafté est en
réalité si ça te ça te convient pas si
tu penses que tu peux encore te
représenter la drogue dans un ou deux
ans et améliorer parce que tout est une
histoire de tous n'est pas une histoire
de corte mais çà çà çà çà joue quand
même si tu pense qu'en fait tu peux
améliorer cette côte connaissons dans un
environnement collectif différents dans
un championnat où tu pourrais peut-être
plus te montrer aux yeux des scot ce que
pourrait être ce que peut être la nba
pour hugo besson par exemple ou si tu
penses si mal comme cazalon je ne sais
pas s'il va rester à mega l'ex ou méga
soccernet mai
peut-être qu'ils pensent qu'ils
pourraient devenir plus titulaire dans
cette équipe là je bosse un peut-être
avoir des minutes dans en proie dans un
meilleur club dans celui où ils étaient
l'an passé et alan en fait ils m'ont ri
excuse moi je te coupe mais pour mes
gars cci et cazalon en fait il rien
d'étonnant puisque en cours d'année déjà
le son agent avait twitté en mode cette
année c'est l'année de petru cette case
avant ça sera l'année prochaine
ouais mais cazalon lilas pour ça qu'on
l'avait un peu gris on pensait qu'il
allait peut-être pas y aller et puis
finalement il a mis son nom je pense que
c'était pour voir ce qu on le sait ce
qu'on pouvait lui dire quoi ce qu'on lui
dise qu'on lui a dit ça va peut-être
conforté dans son idée que ça serait
plus 2022 pour lui et puis surtout il
est sur une pente plutôt incertain
depuis la moitié de la saison donc
peut-être la raison de continuer à
prendre de la confiance et aider des
bons retours
c'est vrai ça c'est ce que tu as vu
puisque tu es tu t'es pencher sur son
jeu assez assez récemment il ya d'autres
prospects on parlait de petru 7 dans son
équipe joe beach pour l'année prochaine
effectivement cazalon qui qui espère
toujours être drafté qui espère du coup
ce que tu disais alan avoir une
meilleure cote pour expliquer qu'on
poursuivre en fait les explications il
ya des espèces de sondages c'est comme
la présidentielle ça donne pas la vérité
mais mais ça donne une idée du paysage
il ya une espèce de sondage auprès des
des équipes nba avant la draft et donc
les joueurs reçoivent les résultats de
ces sondages terre on va dire t'as
plutôt temps 2 % de chances d'être
drafté fin de premier tour 30% de
chances début de second et c est ça
marche pareil pour la green room
d'ailleurs la fameuse green room où sont
invités en fait les vins prospects qui
ont dont le nom est le plus ressortie
chez les gm du premier tour qui doivent
qui doivent dire si vous deviez faire un
top 25 vous mettrez équipe dans et les
noms qui ressortent le plus eh bien ce
sont les vins de la green room
voilà le fonctionnement est expliqué
dans un article qui espionne qui est
gratuit pour une fois qu'ils aient date
d'aujourd'hui du 20 juillet le joueur
qui ne va pas la draft et qui nous a le
plus surpris
en l'annonçant
c'est rocco père kassim c'est le croate
que nous on avait je crois on a encore
on n'a pas encore mises à jour mais on a
20e n'avait 20e sur notre big board
notre classement donc des meilleurs
prospects de cette draft des meilleurs
candidats donc c'est à dire qu'on le
voyait enfin selon nous il pouvait être
choisi au premier tour comme dylan il
faut un peu s'extraire de sa vie qu est
ce que tu sais tu sais c'est peut-être
un peu fort mais est-ce que tu as
entendu des bruits pour expliquer
pourquoi il se retire n 7o qu'opère
cassine scellier comme tu le disais au
retour que les joueurs peuvent avoir via
leurs agents vial et vial et scouts nba
j'imagine que dans les retours en tout
cas on va dire que le le côté deuxième
tour a été prépondérant il a toujours
été annoncée sauf cette année comme
improbable premier tour quand il était
quand il a remporté même si ça fait
jeune l'euro u16 et qu'il était lui ai
dit on en parlait même comme un futur
lottery pick entre temps il ya eu
beaucoup de kilos et un changement de
position et on va dire que ce qui les
retours qu'ils ont eut été vraiment en
deçà de 2
de leurs attentes au clan auckland par
catherine et maintenant on les échos
qu'on peut avoir aussi c'est que il est
assez déçu de ce que le cibona zagreb a
pu lui proposer cette année en terme de
travail individuel en termes de
visibilité et donc de l'année prochaine
il ne jouera pas au cibona zagreb casser
les échos qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est pas
encore on sait pas encore où mes a
priori clubs européens qui jouera en
coupe d'europe pour une mise en avant
on va dire plus plus logique dans la
construction d'un parcours de
progression c'est à peu près musique
rock au père cassine c'est quelqu'un
pierre toi que tu as tu as vu jouer
juste qu'on en parle il ya le scouting
report et sur notre site
il n'y a pas de problème si vous voulez
des détails mais pierre simplement toit
pour toi c'est quand même surprenant tu
voyais quand même un talent premier tour
chez schaeffer catching oui surtout
qu'il était attendue depuis longtemps
il avait c'est sûr qu'il est qu'ils
n'évoluent pas dans la meilleure ligue à
haut niveau le plus élevé en europe mais
ça lui permettait d'engranger du des
minutes et puis l'expérience et des
responsabilités car on voit le combo
mobilité à tahiti sa salle et c'est
quand même de bons espoirs pour ses
draps c'est un grand ailier comme les
aime bien l âme tu l'avais 15e
ouais je l'avais remis 15e juste avant
juste ce week-end en fait j'ai alors
regardé pour ça qu'en fait tu vas le
proto que j'ai twitté serrano qu'est-ce
qui fait puis ensuite en fait j'ai le
choix c'est jonathan régime honni qui a
dit que le elle avait entre 30 et 40 et
que c'est un peu les rôles les échos
qu'il a vu que la paire cassez ne les
voulait être un premier tour et qu' ils
voulaient booster sa cote pour 2022
j'avais pas que ce serait possible pas
au cibona mais on verra comment ça va se
passer de produits
nico pour finir sur père keith chine
c'est quelqu'un qui tue nous décrivait
comme un caractère gros caractères
imagine qui doit être vraiment blessé
par les retours qu'il a eues on peut
imaginer que ce soit un petit coup de
pied au cul bénéfique pour sa carrière
au site
oui oui on peut le penser effectivement
c'est un gros caractère et c'est
vraiment je pense très positif de savoir
qui va évoluer autres parcs au cibona
parce que pour tous ceux qui ont assisté
à le
les juniors il ya un an un an et demi
c'est quand même très rare de voir un
joueur de cet âge là décidé de sortir du
banc et décidé de rentrer quand il veut
en gros le cibona zagreb était trop
petit pour pour lui et il dépasse et
l'institution et du coût en terme de
travail on le rappelle il était
capitaine plus jeune capitaine de
l'histoire du soldat zagreb c'est un
donc j'ai hâte de le voir dans un autre
rôle que celui de rôle principal mais et
puis qui se mouillent comme tu disais
qu'ils se bougent il a pris une claque
maintenant il va faire que les faits
sont là et mis dans le je crois dans le
rapport sur 1,2 le body language était
vraiment un négatif le tout la partie
off the wall défense donc il va arriver
dans un club avec un comment dire un
effectif à séduire un coach à séduire on
espère voir ces parties là sous un autre
angle
c'est un peu c'est vrai je m'excuse mais
alex mais j'ai lu un truc comme quoi il
est plus jeune que plein de mecs qui
sont potentiellement notre et beekkant
donc oui les de fin d'année
fin 2002 il est plus jeune que cetto en
graines ou des jours comme ça donc en
granit est si catastrophique que ça pour
même l'argument de l'âge encore il peut
être très bon l'année prochaine et alex
tu posait la question du talent pour moi
tous les jours un talent premier tour
oui oui oui oui oui je crois qu'on était
tous à peu près d'accord d'ailleurs
là-dessus
le talent est évident d'autres n'ont
donc qui était plus attendue au deuxième
tour ont retiré leur candidature
ariel sportif reebok badji deux
intérieurs car le [ __ ] c'est
l'espagnol et et gabriele proshina qui
avait de plus en plus la cote
donc oui j'ai re l'entendez des trucs
sur prochain oui c'est étonnant ça ça
pouvait chopin second tour aux jeunes
sans trop forcer
probablement on va parler de ceux qui
seront là du coup on va commencer par
les français
le français vous que vous voyez si vous
êtes parisien dans le métro tout on est
sur des jets réalisateur égérie adidas
beaucoup de swat pour jamie begarin
bègles comme il est appelé sur ses
affiches
alors pierre il reste donc ça veut dire
qu'il a eu des retours plutôt positif
présente nous présente le joueur ceux
qui connaissent pas les gars qui jouait
en deuxième
c'est ça ils arrivent ils viennent
pierre sa deuxième année avec le paris
basket donc en pro b où ils ont obtenu
la montée andy pettitte sûr
la journée donc c'est un grand arrière
qui peut évoluer qui évolue surtout sur
le poste 2 2 1 et 3 il peut dépanner et
où sa qualité première depuis qu'il est
jeune c'est quand même son athlétisme
couplet à sa défense sur l'homme et qui
a développé pendant ces deux années
robail basket son tir surtout avec le
coach qui a été bien ça a été très
souligné par le coach dans un article
qui a été publié
longtemps sur le site de la lnb et qui
donc il a été il est passé par initiale
puis les sorties en avance pour aller à
signer en pro b
ensuite il a été un défi du bit a value
by europe et il a été au camp global de
billets dab by l'année dernière il
semble absolument basketball without
borders
c'est le programme on avait fait une
interview avec un des responsables après
la draft l'année dernière il a été
invité aux gee lee ken non si c'est sa
geely comme s'il appelle ça comme ça
djelic combined with edge et les
combrailles
donc c'est pas le nba comme bein c'est
la division 2 pour simplifier donc
certains on doit gagne pendant cette
cette semaine enfin ces quelques jours
de détection c'est comme le combat qu'il
y ait des mensurations des exercices de
tir d'agilité c'était un exercice
physique et certains gagnent ticket pour
le vrai combat
ça n'a pas été le cas de deux begarin
mais malgré tout les les échos qu'on a
pu avoir les workouts était pas si mal
passé et donc le fait qu'ils restent à
la draft ça veut dire que il a sans
doute eu une vraie carte à jouer alors
alan pour toi ça serait plutôt second
tour si ensuite on une tombe big board
de plus en plus je me dis que si c'est
tellement un projet athlétique
enfin c'est voire extrêmement athlétique
et c'est il est jeune très jeune c'est
un joueur extrêmement athlétique brut
encore il n'y a pas et j'ai trouvé même
si c'était mieux avec de ce que j'ai vu
en pro b j'ai pas vu énormément
personnellement le plus que j'ai vu des
jeunes d'ailleurs c'est en équipe de
france de jeunes et ça fait longtemps
qu'on la prenne une équipe de france de
jeunes malheureusement mais je pense
qu'une équipe qui a plusieurs choix en
fin de premier tour où une équipe qui a
plusieurs choix en début de second tour
et veut très des en fin de premier tour
pour assurer les quatre années de
contrat et donc racontera d'avoir
begarin son sein plus longtemps pourrait
le faire parce que c'est un joueur en
fait qui a vraiment besoin d'un poste
développement après draft on le draft
pas pour le mettre sur le terrain et
gagner des matches en nba je pense pas
mais c'est tellement il aux matériaux
étaient tellement est intéressant je
trouve pour pour la nba que à oui même
si moi je les entends entre 38 et 45
jeudi jeu ça me dérangerait pas qu'une
équipe lca plusieurs choix pour puisse
faire ce choix là plus haut donc est ce
qu'on pense à une équipe en particulier
chez toi
bon ok ici qu'il ya 34 et 36 mais bon
ils ont le 18 ça me paraît au coût de 18
trouve que c'est assez haut mais situe à
34 et le trentin que tu peux monter en
27 28 avec une équipe tchèque a trop de
contrats un peu comme boston l'année
dernière et qui ne peuvent le faire que
l'année dernière il est d'ailleurs il
était monté je crois pour prendre mal
aidons aussi c'était il avait vu un
profil qui pouvait les intéresser à
houston ils ont plusieurs pics dans les
vins mais ça ils peuvent peut-être
qu'ils peuvent rentrer dès 1
descendre et puis prendront le garant un
plus bas mais je pense que c'est plus
dans ce genre de situation qui va
arriver je le vois pas arriver parce que
si on entre dans 20 entre 20 et 30 les
équipes qui sortent des play-offs mais
c'est moi ou alors ces équipes qui ont
récupéré des pics des équipes qui
venaient des [ __ ] qui voulait faire et
plus afrique entre des influences à un
premier tour de draft
je vois plus dans les équipes qui ont
reçu un premier tour de draft qui sont
dans une reconstruction
voilà tu peux tu peux essayer de parier
sur faire confiance dans ton dans son
mode de développement pourrait pour
payer un vrai projet begarin donc pierre
si tu devais donner un axe de travail
alors il ya deux shoots tu l'as dit même
s'il a progressé ca continue pour toi de
quoi il a besoin vraiment pour passer
déclencher le niveau supérieur
plus de haendel selon moi son shoot à
trois points commencent à arriver
il est pas il était à 36% à peu près sur
la fin de saison et on le voyait à
prendre de plus en plus de shoots mais
son haendel
je dirai et je sais pas si c'est son qi
basket mais sa propension à perdre le
ballon pour est un peu lent des
handicapés conscience de l'environnement
etc sur ses gardes
ça vient parfois avec l'expérience mais
il ya aussi des choses à travailler
ok donc jeunes begarin je voulais juste
faire cette présentation puisque ensuite
les prospères internationaux va faire
comme menacée avec les porteurs de
ballon valu les classer en différents en
différents groupes
je vais juste donner lé le ce dont on va
parler ce soir donc des gares un jogging
candidats présentés chez les porteurs de
ballon d'or redire à mosman garuba dont
on a déjà parlé plusieurs fois mais il
ya peut-être un peu plus longtemps qui
ensuite qui va jouer le jeux olympiques
avec l'équipe nationale espagnole albert
and thank god un chouchou de certains
dont on taira mon nom
qui pis est turc qui est à hem dépit de
la liturgie de la bêtise qui donc est
attendu lui aussi dans la green room
tout comme josh qui dit d'ailleurs tout
comme une sonnette garuba donc les ça
veut dire que leurs noms ressortent
parmi les 20 les plus cotés et 20
joueurs les plus cotés de cette draft
rock as you go by this dont on a aussi
parlé dans le dernier podcast sur les
porteurs de ballon et deux joueurs qui
sont belges ou sont passé par la
belgique à mars il a french bloomberg
que nous avons interviews et qui est
donc qu'ils pouvaient suivre les
aventures si vous suivez sur les réseaux
sociaux il n'est pas du tout dans le
secret contrairement à beaucoup de
prospects tout ce qu'il sait que là il
est en bois caoutchouc à sacramento le
salut alors nico pour toi qui est dans
le groupe qui est logique le plus haut
des internationaux sur ton classement
est-ce qu'il y en a plusieurs qui sont
dans le même tiers même palier dans sa
monnaie garuba de mémoire guidy n'est
pas là alors en fait ouais j'ai un peu
raciste j'ai peut-être que les européens
mais faites à oui si tu dis
internationaux guidiez dans le même
tiers ok ok alors par le no2 du match
singing aruba c'est très intéressant à
faire parce que c'est théoriquement
alors pas tout à fait la même position
ça devrait être comme des joueurs qui
sont plutôt portés vers l'intérieur mais
deux styles complètement différents avec
un gars du bas vraie force de frappe
défensive et halpern schengen va sorte
de frappe offensive
comment tu départage les deux comment tu
compare les deux alors ce qu'il ya c'est
que garou bail est en train de me faire
changer d'avis les les derniers matches
amicaux avec l'espagne j'avoue m'ont
impressionné parce que on avait déjà vu
je n'aime pas dire des flashs on est on
avait déjà vu en euroligue des matches
entiers où sa défense lui permettait
d'avoir un vrai impact dès maintenant
sur le terrain
si on doit parler de sunwing aiba c'est
un petit peu thèse antithèse si on
exagère un peu puisque c'est le goon est
connu pour son talent offensif pour ses
mains pour sa capacité à créer pour lui
ou pour les autres
beaucoup le compas à djokic moi je
trouve que c'est une chute de saddam et
c'est une comparaison paresseuse parce
que c'est ben et il a raison thank god
n'est pas djokic djokic anna il y en a
qu'un par contre là où la ressemblance
peut être fait que ces news n'a pas de
grosses qualités athlétiques il a pas un
corps on va dire typique d'un athlète
nba mais il apporte quelque chose qui
est rare avec les mains ou les maquilas
par rapport à par rapport à la taille
mais défensivement
ça peut parfois être un cauchemar de
l'autre côté
ousmane garuba certains n'hésitent pas à
dire qu'il a le potentiel pour être un
on va dire
comptable defensive team voilà defensive
team je cherchais je cherchais le terme
et il est en train de se développer en
attaque où son riz son tir faisait rire
en jeune on a même beaucoup de scouts
qui avait fait quelques croix sur lui
parce que je vois fini physiquement
quand il était n 16 est dominée
seulement physiquement mais il avait
déjà une qualité de passe il avait déjà
une intelligence qui pour moi le faisait
que c'était pas seulement un corps
c'était autre chose maintenant si dragon
ball existaient dans la vraie vie tu
fais une fusion entre ceng uni garuba je
suis pas loin de penser que c'est top 5
de cette draft mais on pense que
l'anglais on peut dire ça et on peut pas
donc du coup garuba pour seng wun ça
serait un pari sur est ce qu'il va être
capable de
de défendre et d'exister sur un sur
internet de billets parce que on ne met
sur quels postes
post 5 c'est un petit post 4 il n'a pas
encore de tirs extérieurs de l'autre
côté garuba apporte peut-être plus de
garanties et pourtant dans mon
classement gmi gémissez ngouna vanves et
robin parce que c'est une histoire de
préférence personnelle c'est une
histoire de préférence personnelle et en
fait ça faisait garuba le groupe
on va dire yellow flag c'est que le
shoot il est au real madrid avec le
peut-être la meilleure cellule de
développement personnel en europe
et pourtant sur les trois dernières
années sont chute à peu progresser il a
progressé mais en termes de gestuelle en
termes de remise il ya toujours des
choses à gommer et certains n'hésitent
pas à dire que drogba ne sera jamais un
tireur fiable moi je n'irai pas jusque
là mais c'est vrai que c'est la raison
pour laquelle je l' ai mis entre
guillemets aussi bas je l'aimais 24e
parce que
l'apport sur le tir à trois points sera
faible maintenant j'ai eu une discussion
avec avec les experts envergure et
j'avoue que le fait qu'on ne pourra pas
mettre seng wun sur des matches de
playoffs
les deux prochaines années fait que je
comprends qu'ils soient aussi bas dans
certains dans certaines banques comme
comme comme celle de comme celle d'alan
par exemple sur serre sur le board
d'alan effectivement c'est une bonne et
au delà de la trentième position alors
vas-y alan explique nous le raisonnement
mais c'est pas que j'aime pas synchrones
en fait oui c'est plus philosophique et
théorique de ce que je recherche dans
mon intérieur aujourd'hui son talent
offensif il est impressionnant faut dire
c'est un voeu il adopta qu'il a dominé à
son âge la lecture que je regrette
cependant qu'en fait il n'est pas fou je
trouve que orgie peuvent une moitié mais
la lecture qu'en termes d'intérieur je
trouve que c'était pas très en europe
via mieux quoi je trouve en termes de
gros babar cher à nico ouais même bien
creux qu'on place le bonjour
ouais bah j'ai pas vu le match contre
mam j'ai été je pense que là il est il
ya été pas ridicule du tout donc mais
j'ai vu j'ai vu de trois matchs et les
bals d'ailleurs le macho où il était un
petit peu plus en difficulté je crois
que c'était contre l'inde louait fès un
des leurs un de ces matches là en fait
illégaux qui c'est le dernier joueur de
mon tir 4 donc mais un tiers qui va de
15 à 39
donc il est quand même dans le même
groupe que garde dans la commune choc
loup-garou bas et 21 ou 22 5 goudé 39 ah
oui je resterai tous les jours gare aux
boîtes devant things may
cl c'est ici une équipe croit devant le
talent offensif et veut faire de 5 goût
d'un sixième homme qui apportera
peut-être de l'attak en nba ça ne
dérange pas en plus il a 18 ans ou 19
ans je crois ils servent de mes deux
donc il faut encore progresser
en fait c'est juste que je pense pas que
c'est un gunt défendent à des membres en
playoff nba
je pense que il ya des limitations
d'être limitations physiques trop de
limitation athlétique la compréhension
saylan ya pas de soucis mais je pense
qu'il se fera ciblées en fait tous les
intérieurs se fonde ciblées et même des
intérieurs de bien plus athlétique est
meilleur que lui ceux de ce fonds limite
sortir du terrain donc j'ai peur de ça
après l'argument offensif comme l'a dit
nico comme le dit ben moi quand on me
parle de nicolay au kitsch pour me
vendre un prospect fort en attaque
et pas physiques postes intérieurs jeudi
mais c'est pas possible en fait il faut
en fait il faut pour chaque prospect
il faut qu'on ait un médian fait pas le
meilleur le meilleur qu'on appelle ça la
meilleure destinée possible il sera
jamais ni collectif nicole richie en a
qu'un et en fait nicolas litchi là où il
est tellement fort c'est qu'il arrive à
compenser ces déficiences défense m
en étant j'ai pas vu j'ai commencé le
basket il ya moins de temps que d'autres
mais c'est le meilleur pivot offensif
que j'ai vu morgan peut-être enfin il
est je pense que même ceux qui regardent
depuis très longtemps ils ont du goût de
meilleur que lui il est incroyable il
arrive à compenser le fait d'être pas
très bon en défense parce à 6,5 ghosn
si si en fait la destinée de saint guen
sait devoir compenser cette limitation
physique en étant bas un jour historique
au poste de pivot en attaque je préfère
pas parié contre ça va juste au fait
est-ce que ça a un rapport avec
l'endroit où ils sont drafté puisque si
on parle de deux joueurs qui sont un tir
au dessus en étendant le tir 3 du coup
qu'ils vont avoir un développement
loterie du cou qui vont avoir peut-être
un gros le plus important dans leur
équipe
est ce que à ce nom alors que là on
parle de joueurs qui vont qui pour être
drafté après le 15ème position par des
équipes qui veulent d'avant qui ont
davantage à calendrier avoir moyen terme
qu'à long terme
est ce que ça joue chez toi le
calendrier des équipes qui
potentiellement peuvent drafté au oui ça
peut jouer mais comme on disait tout à
l'heure pour bekaert je pourrais avoir
une idée car plusieurs pays qui se dit
voilà je je parlais sur le talent
offensif de d'un sans goût ni après en
fait voilà je ne doive pas j'aime pas
déjà je doive pas les intérieurs ça ne
m'intéresse pas trop où papa au en fait
donc c'est en fait c'est que vous n'êtes
pas les 30 m sur bornes mais il n'est
pas jour il n'est pas genre 15e
intérieur dans mon classement tout ceci
je fais un casse dont par position jeu
il doit être c'est un coup ci je pense
ou quelque chose comme ça mais c'est
juste que je préfère voilà m moi je
mettrais pas un premier tour de draft
donc un contrat garanti de 4 ans sur un
joueur dont je sais déjà qui a une
déficience qui fait que
faudrait qu'ils soient soient
historiques offensivement pour rester
sur le terrain ou alors qu'on est
vraiment quatre joueurs autour
défensivement et un schéma qui qui
permet de masquer je pense qu'il masque
est un joueur que je prends mon premier
tour en fait c'est un peu ça m est alors
mon contre-arguments après je donner la
parole à pierre contre-arguments en fin
de compte
question est ce qu'on a vu des joueurs
ces dernières années en finale de
conférence faire moins de 2 m 05 ne pas
savoir shooter à trois points et avoir
plus de dix minutes de temps de jeu
aussi bon soit-il en défense tu peux
donc pour une main de garou ben oui andy
seth rogen veut faire de m un des huit
deuxièmes sais pas je pose une colle
mais mais je crois moi j'ai cherché à
éviter
je crois qu'il doit peut-être je trouve
pas juste pourquoi je les petits cg 4
shooteur autour de garou bas ça me
dérange pas sinon il est pas jouable
encore une bien moi j'ai garuba de 0,3
avec nomix panne à 7,2 à ta des chiffres
qu'on a
ok de 0,3 donc c'est pas mal c'est pas
si ma faim je le pensais un peu plus
petit que de 0,3 avec donc deux vins
quasiment donc de 18 2 17
pierre comment tu compare les deux
puisqu'on est parti là dessus ou alors à
part si guy dit un cran plus haut que
les deux possibles non non qui sont dans
le même panier les trois mois j'ai
schengen qui est dans mon premier tiers
tout seul et garou baquet d'un mon
deuxième tiers et guy diquélou mon
troisième est tout autant d'accord alors
donc philosophiquement qu'est ce qui te
plaît c'est chez penguin qu on a déjà
dit beaucoup de choses mais qu'est ce
que tu peux développer comme un
commentaire ben droit déjà c'est un
joueur de bath un joueur de basket ça
c'est pour moi ce que je voudrais ce que
je vais faire mon équipe
si je peux ajouter un mec qui joue
basket ça m'arrange puisque je sais que
quand il sera sur le terrain il pourra
il aura au moins une production minimale
au moins en attaque et alan parler de
délimitation défensive je pense que si
une fois qu'il va arriver dans un dans
un contexte nba qui va devoir à jouer 82
matchs dans la saison qui sera avec
peut-être des meilleurs des meilleurs
stats il va pouvoir encore progresser
physiquement j'ai vu une photo il n'ya
pas longtemps où j'ai l'impression qu'il
était devenu un peu plus musculeux déjà
depuis la fin des playoffs turc et voilà
pour moi c'est un mec qui a une qui a
touché et un palette offensive et je te
passe que garou bas n'a pas encore même
si garuba plutôt bon passeur un oui et
puis même il a commencé à développer son
tir à trois points dans le corner lui
cellules lui pour moi ce sera vraiment
c'est un mec qui a un peu d'être comme
ils disent aux états unis l'oph loeb
mais aisling donc qu'il peut mais tu
parles de gargouilles poli peu quand il
peut se développer un très bon ok tu as
ouais tu vois tu vois oui tu veux dire
s'ils foutent pas du tout il servira à
rien merci chou type étrennant pau a
piqué et donc pour pour schengen et tu
parlais disait tu parles de ton papa
pessimisme justement pas optimiste non
plus mais sur le menace pas défensif
qu'est-ce qui peut compenser selon toi
la parente manque de mobile apparent
manque de mobilité qu'il a pour le
moment
bah ce sera peut-être peut-être là est
ce que le fait de pouvoir de pouvoir
mettre à abonnés sa force
moi je les ai vus faire railler condé
des intérieurs plus gros que lui n'en a
parlé contre efes où il ya de steen
qui lui a qui devait lui rendre 20 kilos
qu'il a bien contenu et même contre le
lituanien qui pendant les à la ligue
contre la lituanie non pardon celui qui
joue pour les pays sabonis voilà sabonis
là j'étais en train de regarder le match
de la lituanie contre l'hapoël sabonis
pas ce point pour un monstre physique et
things cas isolé ddd vis-à-vis il a il a
quand même la tenue
ok donc c'est intéressant donc tu as
pour l'instant c'est ngounou juste poser
une question ou pas oui tu peux
l'argument c'est un vrai joueur de
basket cstc juste esthétique ou c'est
autre chose
je pense que c'est pour moi c'est un
croiseur de basket aussi ouais non je
porte je pense que j'ai eu que je suis
biaisé sur sur ça c'est juste que j'ai
vu un gars ou pas faire plus de deux
mauvaises décisions que schengen mais a
bien sûr que gorgui mbaye ne croit que
genre de basket on devient on n'est pas
un pipi de 8,16 à 14 ans je pense que
c'est parce que juste en iran moi j'ai
la rage est une réponse aussi alan
puisque moi aussi comme pierre g thank
you un tiers au dessus d'une guerre ou
bas et le raisonnement est encore plus
biaisée
mais le en fait il ya un tiers qui
s'appelle genre j'en parlais a récemment
donc le premier canine game très bien
ensuite
john green evans meublé james ex pour
certains pas seulement deux petits bars
dont certains sont d'autres bref les
deuxièmes ou sont des joueurs dont on
est quand même à peu près sûr qu'ils
vont faire une carrière et ensuite il ya
un troisième tiers et pour moi ça c'est
le tiers du risque
c'est pour ça qu'il ya souvent des
échecs entre 5 et 15 5 et 15 5e
c'est le tiers du risque mais c'est le
tiers aussi du risque avec une grosse
récompense parce que ce sont des joueurs
qu'on quelque chose de spécial pour moi
garou bas mais aussi monde
fantômes défenseurs soit il c'est pas
evan mobiles il n'y a pas quelque chose
de spécial en défense ce qui n'est pas
il n'est pas assez grand docteur faute
il passé dans schengen la manière dont
je le vois jouer
bah en fait quelqu'un qui à 19 ans qui a
des mains comme ça qui fait des passes
comme ça qu'ils mènent alors certes
c'est sûr des flashs mais qui met des
stades bac d'abord à 3 mètres 4 mètres
et puis un jour il en prend un
internationaux en fin de possession il
le met à 7 m enfin c'est rare moi c'est
ce que je cherche un bon tiers 3 c'est
la rareté
on peut être dans quelle période lp
rensing alternance ngone pour moi il est
plus rare qu ousmane garuba il est dans
le délire du risque sharif cooper et
pousse à mettre là quoi exactement
alors oui je suis d'accord c'est plus
dur à jouer en playoffs mais mais je
pense que il ya des il peut y avoir des
contre exemples a toujours des joueurs
des joueurs qui doit aussi améliorer
leur mobilité il ya aussi une mobilité
fines chez synck ghosn parce que nicolas
preuve lors du premier podcast parlait
de voilà de quelqu'un qui était un
buffle sur le bas du corps et voilà
qu'ils avaient des idées il doit de fait
sur le haut du corps un peu le docteur
jekyll mr à être entre le bas et le haut
et et jeu malgré le fait qu'il soit très
forte sur le bas il a dit il a des
appuis de ouf et donc s'ils arrivent à
bouger ses pieds aussi bien
offensivement ça veut dire que alors il
va pas les bouger sur des grandes
distances mais ça veut dire que sur des
défenses en europe
il est capable de contenir sur quelques
mètres quelqu'un alex sur le point
d'interrogation que peu à voir alan pour
moi en fait en ayant vu en moi je vais
connu bouboule en jeunes là c'est la
première année où il a
commencé à travailler sur son corps il
ya encore de la place il ya pour moi le
physique de comptes actuels de thank you
c'est un physique avant draft nba et
puis ça sera peut-être pas la
transformation de dwight howard autres
joakim noah mais il va y avoir une vraie
transformation ils vont ajouter des
muscles ils vont ils vont travailler sur
sur son corps et je suis sûr qui sera
dans deux trois ans il sera pas ridicule
ça sera jamais un garuba en défense mais
il va réussir à faire autre chose que ce
qui nous montre aujourd'hui que le cicta
il est pour ça que tu la onzième version
c'est toi qui l'a le plus haut malgré
tout l'amour que j'ai pour lui j'ai pas
réussi à le pardon j'ai une question
pour nico oui ainsi pierre luc tu l'as
tu l'avais déjà vu en u16 nicolas quand
il était un peu plus en plus gros est ce
que tu as vu une évolution au niveau des
déplacements ou à les déplacer
pratique oui oui oui mais le temps alors
je vais te dire un an du cese
il était tellement costaud qu'eux ils
pouvaient compenser par le par le coût
des pôles on va dire et avec les jambes
souvent en retard donc maintenant j'ai
l'impression qu'il a il a moins ce côté
très costaud parce qu'il a perdu
beaucoup de poids en haut du corps mais
que le bas on est passé de
mauvais à
pas ça parce que là il ya beaucoup de
gens qui je trouve qu'il le quadrille
nature sur un plot en défense mais en en
geek turquie n'est pas n'est pas non
plus ridicule c'est pas imploser exagère
lalique turquie alors s'il n'a pas il
n'y a pas énormément d'intérieur golgoth
ya quand même des arrières de qualité et
puis il faut aussi rajouter que abc pts
as c'est le joueur intérieur il n'y a
pas de meilleur
il souffle par et voilà et donc du coup
forcément et ben les efforts il défait
en attaque et les fait pas en défense
oui parce qu'on compte beaucoup sur lui
offensivement aussi bon on a fait le
tour de thank god ça va devenir de plus
en plus durs sont des coûts numico de
faire le tour de ses moon
mais voilà on il ya deux écoles et non
peut-être aucune des deux co a raison
mais toujours est il que alan et nico
ont dans le même panier du joueur al
kanz ngono yarouba pierre aa seng où
notre un peu plus aux pierres parle nous
de josh qui dit du coup on en a parlé
dans le dernier podcast donc meneur plus
de deux mètres il doit faire un
vannetais que garou bas à peu près
peut-être maintenant plus de deux mètres
voilà qu'est ce qui est qu'est ce que tu
aimes bien dans son jeu et pourquoi tu
te mettrais un palier au dessous du
seuil gargouille ouais donc moi je les à
2 03 m
qu'est ce que j'aime chez lui
ça va être une réponse va être un peu
biaisé parce que j'ai pas le lait ce que
j'ai vu de lui
j'ai vraiment pas apprécié par rapport à
toute la hype con qu'il a autour de lui
depuis deux ans c'est aussi site de
garrel le produit de la formation
française vis celui de la maison
australienne sort d'où ils ont
clairement la tête de mounier c'est ça
lui il sort de les sites dieu de leur
insep locaux local de l'anzhi academy
est on
la tente depuis deux ans et déjà qu'il
sera en nba dans le programme des jeunes
des écoles et on nous en faisait le
nouveau en plus vous en parlait dans le
dernier podcast
le nouveau la mélo de la nba les j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a pas répondu
aussi fort aux attentes que qui étaient
placés sur lui moi j'ai des jamais été
de marquer que son jeu orpik et drôle
son jeu offensif était quasiment
inexistant s'il n'était pas sur pick'n
roll avec plus de 400 shoot il avait
tendance à s'enfoncer après dans la dans
la dèche dans la défense ça et même le
championnat en lui-même m'a pas beaucoup
plus de ce que j'ai eu à oui c'est ça ne
peut pas jouer dans une évaluation ainsi
tu peux dire l'opposition étant
exceptionnel une opposition et puis les
joueurs qu'il entend qui l'entouré me
font dire que la hype risque d'être trop
grande etc
je lui souhaite vraiment pas mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est le genre de
joueur qui peut bost delà des ces deux
premières années
ok ça c'est intéressant nico s car
j'étais pris par surprise tu avais pas
préparé ce que tu as tes notes sur guy
dit ouais bah je alors moi je suis passé
à côté de la hype parce que je suis pas
forcément un très grand utilisateur de
twitter donc du coup ça me plaît ça me
protège de ce genre de trucs celui d'un
coup quand j'ai regardé moi j'ai adoré
jeu
effectivement en dehors du pick and roll
c'est pas d'un mais par contre sur
pick'n roll ça vaut le coup d'oeil quand
même donc je j'aime beaucoup après
j'entends les limites athlétiques
ok peut-être qu'il a dix ans de retard
qu'il ya dix ans ça aurait pu être une
sorte de steve nash australien s'est pas
mais maintenant que steve nash qui
shoote à 50,44 oui oui c'est vrai je
j'abuse pour l'instant sur le sur le tir
on est encore loin d'ici de steve nash
ça c'est sûr mais c'est vraiment un
joueur agréable à voir jouer
après tout les tous les points
interrogations sur le niveau athlétique
sur sur la défense je les comprends
maintenant
et franchement si on regarde les
dernières draft le top ten
il n'y a pas qu'à d'étape défenseur
c'est ça moi j'ai été plutôt rassurés
par ces dernières sorties sais pas si je
les fais je voulait amender son scouting
et portes j'avais été un peu dur sur la
sur le côté défensif j'ai été plutôt
agréablement surpris par le fait qu'ils
tiennent qui tiennent des joueurs quand
même assez athlétique et qui bouge assez
bien ses pieds par rapport à ce qu'il
faisait en saison après la question
halal on va pas passer trop de temps sur
guy dit puisqu'on a déjà parlé c'est en
fait comme disait pierre et ce qui peut
peser autrement qu'en étant le principal
porteur de ballon et du coup est ce que
son équipe peut être très efficace avec
lui en porter de bain au pas dans les
premières années non après un mois de
l'année dernière c'est qu'il est habillé
dans un tir apparemment rider en tierce
partie jackass et les internationaux il
étire 1 avec garou bahraoui garuba wrens
oui et dans tous ses droits c'est ça il
était la prise de risque tu as tout dit
à l'heure en fait sur cette espèce de
tir ou bien étaient des certitudes sur
les premiers jours de ce tir là mais sur
la fin où nous avons essayé de prendre
des récits un mois ces fermes envers le
talent que je vais alors c'est bizarre
vu que je vais pas dire le talent
deux singles comme vous l'avez dit mais
je vais sur le talent de playmaker
créateurs de just qui dit défensivement
il défendra pas les meneurs et c'est
très bien parce que en fait il jouera
par sa taille sera il jouera avec des
joueurs plus petits que lui c'est sûr ou
alors ils sont vraiment des line-up trop
trop grand et ça marchera pas mais à les
saucisses et le tir maala mécanique je
ne suis pas eu tout un un docteur du
tout loin de là
et puis souvent les pourceaux les
pourcentages route doivent aussi rentrer
en jeu mais j'ai un peu de doutes sur
son sur son sur son jeu aux tirs mais
sont les making fuck pour moi il restera
sur un terrain bien oui et c'est ça et
puis ça ouais c'est ire de rendre de
plus en plus et surtout pour conclure là
dessus et si vous avez lu le scouting
report c'est quelque chose avec lequel
je conclu guy dit à chaque fois que je
les ai vus jouer je n'en suis cognée
quand même à chaque fois ils étaient
meilleurs
alors moi contrairement à nico je trouve
inesthétique haut possible
j'ai vraiment j'aime pas ce joueur est
du coup j'essaie de mettre ça de côté
quand enfin j'aime pas voir jouer quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'ils contrôlent très
mal son corps et et du coup ça a pesé
premièrement dans une évaluation mais
force est de constater que c'est
quelqu'un qui continue de progresser à
chaque sortie donc ça c'est très
intéressant qui dit donc nico toi tu
l'as à peu près dans les dents là même
un peu plus bas que garou bas il est
ouvert aux jeux les 16 18 ans 16 il est
en 16 10 10 et kharouba où il est un peu
plus bas
effectivement mais ils sont pareils dans
le même même choc
oui juste poursuit pour a rappelé qu'il
était aussi avec l'équipe d'australie
pour la préparation des jeux olympiques
je crois qu'ils n'ont pas encore annoncé
les 12 mai il faisait partie du roster
pour la préparation
effectivement il a joué contre le
nigeria ces matches là
le mans qui m'encourage / heriot
oui effectivement j'ai pas regardé je
pense qu'ils en ont c'est une ou deux
mais je pense qu'ils ont fait bref on
vérifiera ça plus tard si mal préparé ça
on peut tout cas ce qui est le prochain
sur thalys nico quand on descend dans
ton classement des internationaux on n'a
pas prévu d'en parler mais aldama et je
les mettrais bruit parce que je veux que
tu fous amoureux
oui alors juste pour préciser que c'est
vrai qu'on ne peut pas parler al-dam ans
je n'ai pas mis dans les programmes du
podcast puisque saint geoirs et si oui
que ça que je n'ai pas mis simplement on
peut en dire un mot en français
voteraient oui comme trans wagner
exactement et je crois que c'est tout
cas d'autres au dessus mais oui si on
excepte kyle jones qui va ramener en mai
oui ouais donc est ce que tu peux
représenter aldama qui connaissent pas
ce que c'est c'est quelqu'un qui garde
son nom à la draft et du coup on pense
qu'il ya une promesse qui traîne quelque
part peut-être pas au premier tour mais
en tout cas c'est étonnant ouais je vous
donnais les indices après prendre la
conclusion que vous voulez mais bon ils
ne comptent y par d'espagne il a une
cote incroyable et à la surprise
générale il va dans une
petite fac pour jouer contre des
dentistes et des pompiers donc il se
fait des matches à 20 cents sont sans
changer de maillot à la fin du match
sans avoir besoin de prendre sa douche
et et disparaît tout simplement à la
proche de la draft les espagnols de
pense aux états unis les américains ne
pensent en espagne au final il est aux
états unis donc il ya de fortes chances
quand même qu'ils aient une petite
promesse qui traîne à droite à gauche et
que est ce qu'on a vu son nom dans aucun
work out et exhale les équipes
commençaient à dire on avoir karl
qu'intel inquiet quant à l'udc elle dame
à 0 et pourtant il est il restera là et
pour parler de son profil aldama c'est
presque un seven footer qui peut être
utilisé en scratch live donc certains se
posent des questions sur le physique par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont pu voir le
la famille aldama parce qu'il ya le papa
il ya l'oncle sont des anciens sportifs
professionnels basket un professionnel
pivot à chaque fois plutôt costaud en
même temps une certaine élégance une
technique il
il est je pense que si senti avait joué
dans une grosse fac on en parlerait
comme d'un potentiel de triple oui et
puis c'était un beau joueur
oui et ça c'est intéressant moi j'aime
bien eu beau jeu donc aldama et ensuite
au pardon j'avais posé une caissette
petru savent très bien
alors pour tout seul ou est ce qu'il est
dans un panier de plusieurs histoires
qu'on fasse un pet rousset alors à yayi
mais bon on va pas en y jouant 26 et
ouais begarin et ensuite on descend et
on trouve du blind berg du yoruba it is
ok ils sont tous dans le même panier
cela ou clairement pour moi je pète
rousseff est en dessous begarin est en
dessous bryan berg
ok alors pète rousseff
on en a parlé dans un oeil d'or dogs un
épisode de underdog ce que je vous
invite à les écouter pierre a fait son
scouting report simplement pierre toi tu
là où hop et rousseff dans ton
classement
je me je les ai mis en pas de garuba
d'amande ya 2 juste avant vide avant guy
dit oui oui parce que tout y est plutôt
optimiste sur son côté le fait qu'il
shoote de plus en plus du côté de mes
gars aux carmes et moi je l'adoré mans
ce monde chaud pour la cour la peau
prochaine pour la draft
j'adore ce qui est beau petit shoot et
qu'il ait réussi à dominer surtout une
ligue européenne
il a fini 1 bis pied meilleur scoreur de
la ligue adriatique
donc pour moi c'est quand même des
dépôts signaux pour pour quelqu'un qui
était parti de les états unis pour le
district arrière pour avoir travaillé
sur lui et rousseff pour moi c'est
vraiment high risk reward parce que dans
le on va dire le côté psychologie il y
en a beaucoup
notamment du côté de gonzaga qui pense
que mentalement c'est pas quelqu'un qui
aime travailler c'est pas quelqu'un qui
aime se faire mal et il a le profil
à prendre un contrat nba à rester sur le
banc tranquillement pas demander grand
chose et ensuite revenir jouer en europe
en euroligue avec le compte en banque
bien rempli en mai n'ont eu une belle
vie tranquille de l'autre côté ça peut
devenir le nouveau de manta sabonis donc
on le spectre ont quand même ça arrange
non si lille a donné les deux il a donné
il a donné le scénario idéal et le
scénario plat idéal il le droit honnête
oui il fait la même taille il a à peu
près les mêmes stats en sortant de fax à
peu près la même chose
ils essaient shooté à la coopération
n'est pas farfelu moi aussi la première
fois j'ai dire quand même mais quand on
voit la cote qu'avait domaine tasse en
sortant de monza gas est pas fou il
parle l'autre ouais mais c'était une
autre une autre époque
j'ai pas dit qu'il allait devenir
d'hommes entassent à venise jeudi que
dans le meilleur scénario possible ça
pour moi ça peut s'en rapprocher
clairement parce qu'il a dû il a du
talent plein les mains je pense qu'il
peut il être second initiateur d'une
attaque et n'oubliez philippe et
rousseff qui va en play-offs mais en
fait c'est un faux débat puisque je suis
en train de dire que c'est le meilleur
scénario et du coup il ya il ya une
chanson celle entrevue donc entre deux
c'est un pivot backup qui met des points
tout à fait ok toi tu là où alan gelé
tout en bas du tir 5 ans 74
il est dans le même mais il est dans le
même groupe que donc je couds by this
joanes begarin je vais te dire
mikhaïlovski calais sociaux dans la
draft aussi à mars il a ok pierre quelle
qu'elles sentent qu'elles sont et
classement la de tous les joueurs dont
on a parlé ce qui en a qui sont plus
haut que d'autres attentats nadal moi
j'avais au cobaye this you go by this
plus haut qu al hoceima kundu tout ça ce
qui aurait été en fin de second ou
s'attacher
et apprennent en moi j'ai eu les avec
les retraits de avec le retrait de tous
les européens
j'aimais mes tiers qui sont bien dégarni
begarin est en dessous de petro cep dans
le tiers a mené jusqu'au génial j'ai des
gars 1 dames en 4e tiers qui co qui est
encore à ce point du milieu de second
tour parce que pour moi il est à plus à
développer et qu'il est là comme très
jeune et belle rousseff pourrait être
pérenne clegane nico parle-nous vite
fait de nantes hier par longtemps lovitz
et du profil de à mars il a donc allen a
mentionné qu'ils gardent ce moindre acte
juste un profil vraiment rapide très
athlétique très grande et jaouad très
grands excès et elle a du coup très
athlétique c'est bon merci ça sort le
calage qu'on avait fait un épisode sur
lui il ya deux ans et que j'ai vu que ça
a pas beaucoup progressé voire sargasses
et c'est plutôt bon signe à cet âge là
après il ya des outils physique et lui
il a gardé son nom alors soit il n'a pas
reçu de bons sondages soient les
sondages me disent qu'ils peuvent être
pratiquées aussi c'est des choses qui
arrivent
qu'il est haché il ya beaucoup moins de
candidats donc avec tous ces retraites
c'est possible qu'ils le soient nico est
ce que qui j'ai oublié ah oui alors on
va faire un petit un mini débat rapidos
friends chez toi il est en dessous de
plein de monde et chez alan il est
beaucoup plus aux caisses que qu'est-ce
que tu ne vois pas qui de fait qui fait
penser qu'ils croient sans trop y croire
nique
en fait je dirais que quand on fait le
profil devrait nous c'est trop beau par
rapport à la réalité 2
de son jeu dans le sens où on peut aussi
ont fait les grandes lignes on va dire
c'est un initiateur de très grande
taille avec une une qualité de passe
élite c'est vrai mais mine de rien quand
si on enlève les matches qui comptent
pour du beurre etc on compte uniquement
sur les matchs ou face à lui il avait
des joueurs athlétiques il n'est pas
capable de se créer son tir lui même et
parfois ça il est uniquement dans la
recherche de la passe donc du coup très
facile à défendre puisque si drive mais
en fait vous pouvez aller directement
sur les joueurs libres puisqu'il n'a pas
il n'y aura pas plus là encore une fois
j'exagère je fais exprès mais mais du
coup j'ai du mal j'ai du mal à j'ai du
mal à acheter
le vrai ns lindbergh en deuxième tour
donc pour son profil on vous renvoie
vers notre interview sur une chaîne
youtube avec le joueur en question qui a
eu la gentillesse de disponibles trois
bons quarts d'heure pour répondre à nos
questions j'étais avec romain à l'époque
donc de mettre d'ici nous envoyer ses
mensurations
j'avais deux mètres 10 une envergure à
peu près équivalente à sa taille alors
les envergure mensurations diffère selon
eswar cote des keepers ça ça me rend fou
je vois pas comment ça peu différent
d'une équipe à l'autre
donc il a à peu près de m 19 bureaux si
un peu plus que sa taille mais pas
énormément plus est
et puis voilà il est il n'a pas des
grandes mains mais le poids des petites
mains non plus et du coup alain dinin
pense qu'à deux ans que ça me semble oui
ça me ferait plaisir de t'entendre
jamais jallet guyane parce que malade
toi tu là du coup début de deuxième tour
voilà donc le tiers le même tiers que
big n en tire au dessus de belgrade
shout dégâts alors
explications théoriquement il peut
passer de riz blé shooter savent ça
m'intéresse pour mon bon nba je pense
que ça peut être un jour qui va pas j'ai
pas aller jusqu'à dire qu'il va
fluidifier mon attaque non je pense que
c'est pas un joueur qui va ralentir ou
prendre des mauvaises décisions
et s'ils travaillent le tyran spots up
de par sa peut-être sa polyvalence il
pourrait peut-être je pense est un
joueur de un vrai jeu 7 6 1 en huitième
homme de ma de ma rotation si ça si ça
se passe bien pas grand chose d'autre à
dire je n'ai pas vu de match de
championnat belge j'ai vu quatre matches
d'eurocoupe je crois pour préparer les
vidéos de la callas qui ont été insérées
dans le dépistage avec lui donc léger en
échantillons sûrement plus petit
d'autres
je vais peut-être me faire avoir sur ça
mais je crois qu'ils avaient un match le
club de théodose itx je crois que de
teodosic qui emmène virtus bologne de
mémoire c'est salut voila
et alors oui défensivement c'est pas
tout le temps il perd père engagé je
vois très bien ce que dit nico dans le
fait deux en fait il va devoir si il va
s'il veut marquer en contre en nba il va
devoir être un acrobate schumaker mais
en fait je pense que ruine de
marconnelle du spo top donc là ça
pourrait être plus facile de progresser
là dessus
et est ce que comme certains tu fais la
liaison avec beaucoup c'est ce qu'ils
n'ont beaucoup c'est ce qui est à
l'enfance est bien venu me voir je vais
beaucoup je les avais beaucoup beaucoup
en loterie l'an passé donc pour que
c'est ce qui est plus grand ouais
un peu et puis surtout il y plus fluide
khoualed se poser cette question pour
que les fans d'envergure puisque puisse
se dire à l'année nico sont enfin
d'accord sur quelque chose sur ce petit
c'est vrai mon réconcilie les deux
mondes larbitre sera pierre pierre toi
wren ce qu'est ce tu en pense il est ou
par rapport aux autres
pour moi ce jeu moi j'ai pas vu assez de
films pour pour me pour donner un avis
c'est un argument tu es donc c'est pas
que j'aime c'est une très bonne réponse
puisque il n'y a pas assez de gens qui
ne donnent pas leur avis que jamais été
blâmée pour ça moi je suis plus côté
nico je suis désolé parce ngok d'un côté
je puisse côté alan je considère qu'on
lui demandera pas de créer en fait dans
la nba donc je m'en fous qu'ils sachent
pas ce christmas et sont à sept numéros
non ah non j'ai pas la cause est quoi la
menace est numéro un en france il faut
dix fois les moissons à cette numéro 1
s'est taillé plus tire franchement ils
tirent bien j'ai trouvé deux mètres 10 à
willis rapide capable de tirer avec un
dribble de décalage leurs cercles et
pourcentage fondements sont pas
extraordinaires chute donc vous faites
un terrain parce que sa qualité première
aujourd'hui c'est son jeu de passes mais
son jeu de passes il va aider toute
façon son jeu de passes au moment où le
mec qui va sortir sur lui va faire un
drive et comme disait alan il va pas il
va fluidifier la tacc il va pas être le
mec qui sait pas prendre la bonne
décision les rôles players on dit
souvent c'est quand tu reçois la balle
tu dois prendre une décision rapidement
c'est la seule chose qu'on me demande de
lui il peut larry peut le faire il
arrivera un billet et il épousera un
nouveau rôle qui l'a jamais eu celui de
off de bones il est prêt à le faire hein
il est prêt les prêts il nous a aidé à
faire un nom mais des prêts oralement
ouais mais c'est déjà beaucoup en fait
il ya aussi peut-être toujours le même
rôle parce qu'ils étaient toujours tête
forcé de jouer parce qu'il ya pas de
créateurs fort dans son équipe tu peins
en u16 et u18 belgique je veux je veux
pas manquer de respect mais je pense pas
qu'il y avait des énormes initiateurs
peut-être
après anvers oui peut-être plus et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il initiait
plus avec le bon moi je trouve quand il
était avec les titulaires il était
vraiment à l'initiateur regarder en
eurocoupe il à 37% à 3 points sur
quasiment 50 tentatives
après il a 52 % aux lancers francs ça
c'est sur 19 tentatives
ce qui prouve qu'il va pas sur la ligne
parce qu'en fait comme je t'ai dit
athlétiquement il faut pas vraiment
battre son opposant ça c'est vrai mais
il peut fluidifier le jeu et mettre des
tirs je pense y tire il est grand et il
défend il a envie quand même il a envie
et qui bouge plutôt bien pour un mec qui
fait de m'être dit c'est quand tu fais
tu bouges plutôt bien tu es assez long
je les trouvais alors parfois sautes de
concentration mais quand même
relativement concentré dans l'ensemble
le moi j'aime bien le il défend sa sera
là son épitaphe sûr je pense qu'il
serait ravi de l'entendre ce qu'il n'a
pas dû l'entendre souvent moi je pense
qu'il peut défendre
je pense qu'il est capable c'est encore
une fois c'est pareil du risque mais
c'est juste que je préfère prendre les
papas risques mais je préfère quand on
est comme ça qu'ils dont je suis à peu
près sûr de un ou deux trucs en plus de
sa taille plutôt que de prendre mes que
un peu farfelu dont je sais je sais quel
rôle j'ai envie de lui donner
même si effectivement tu as raison il
agit il n'est jamais eu pour l'instant
nico est ce que ya un joueur dont on n'a
pas parlé recasse en bio co by this as
oui on a parlé dans le dernier podcast
pourquoi tu y croies brocas j'y crois
sur sur la vitesse sur la station sur le
culot
voilà il ay là il a vraiment à la fois
la vista le mental pour pour jouer alors
dans le rôle je ne le vois pas autrement
qu'en backup meneur sur voilà on va dire
leader créatif premier créateur d'une
équipe de remplaçants
alors j'ai l'impression que tu les avais
pas mis dans ton board parce que tu
pensais qu'il allait pas se présenter
ainsi tu vas me disant ok pierre même
chose est ce qu'un joueur je vous les
citez programme
il était dans le pub à dire que begarin
pour moi l'aca leur propre approche que
je peux le faire et nicolas tu me diras
si je me trompe c'est qu'il a l'air
d'être expert abondantes ou mecs perdre
à l'économie
ces semis j'ai envie de dire c'est pas
faux non sens où si tu me demandes
aujourd'hui son gros point fort je vais
te dire la vitesse mais au final
techniquement à écoute je je valide et
un goûter
mais on avait on a en a parlé sur le
podcast qu'il fallait pas se fier à
mécanique d'autant que sa rentrée et son
explosivité aussi je les veux rater un
de tout seul en début de deuxième mi
temps et alors que juste avant m hommes
et un peu limite donc j'ai l'impression
que son som athlétisme ça pourrait
limiter un peu ça c'est vrai que l'esc
antenne palais d'un cratère raison qui
me fait douter ce lituanien
est-ce que vous avez un mot de la fin
sinon on lance les musiques de chants je
voudrais passer un bonjour à l'ensemble
du fab five camp qui à la rochelle où je
suis actuellement l'un qui
prêté des locaux magnifiques pour pas
enregistré de podcasts donc un grand
bonjour euh ah
il sera entendu alors c'est pas le fath
five sa saisine
j'y vais avec quatre potes qui ont qui
font mon poids mais voilà les alan pas
le mot de la fin
vive le rhum est prêt on est prêts voilà
les internationaux sont la pierre
notre monsieur international de la date
at-il merci beaucoup moi je passe une
expertise peuvent pas savoir ou aux
développeurs du site de la fiba et vous
parmi les structures prive sa coupe et
il nous écoute
à les écouter c'est pas possible pegasus
mondia sur écoute
merci à vous bon merci à vous tous
on vous donne rendez vous pour un live
voilà ces annonces et on va se
débrouiller maintenant gelé dish a
obligé de faire un live de la semaine de
la draft mais avant puisqu'on aura pas
de vidéo de présentation chez un forcing
pour faire un live avec toutes vos
questions vous aller balancer nos
questions et nous on va être là on va
essayer de vous répondre
et ça va être très très bien donc des
attend évidemment très nombreux en
attendant le big board sur le site c'est
à dire notre classement des 80 meilleurs
joueurs plus de soixante scouting les
porte évidemment sur le site verdure
penser aux abonnés vous à la chaîne
youtube ou podcast sur votre plateforme
d'écouté et puis envoyez nous des coeurs
a plus ciao